senate bill 58 senate 104 i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor
as a result of the copen 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee and selected legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
if necessary participate in this meeting
by zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website the notice for
this meeting does comply with house
rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
603 271
3600 or email hcs
ledge.state.nh dot us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that any votes
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
so i will start the subcommittee meeting
by taking a quick
i'm representative pearson i'm the chair
and i'm president of the rome
representative elector president in the
room
thompson representative oh lord
son of slightly i put you i butcher your
name
it's horrible i apologize representative
schmidt
i am president in my home office here in
dover and i am alone
so i will open the subcommittee hearing
on senate bill
and a reminder to those at home it's an
act relative to the administration of
occupational regulation by the office
of professional licensure and
certification
this is a bill that went through the
senate last term
and died of the omnibus the main gist of
this
is a
to read that's what we're looking for
here is it's a
it's a standardization of practices
within no plc
across the boards that's that's the
reason why it's so thick because it
makes
consistent changes to the to the various
boards
so i'm open to a discussion on this
anybody has any concerns
for more objections
the titles
peter i went through the titles here
just just to highlight the titles when
they changed from board to board
it took me 20 minutes so you know this
was this was quite a quite a long read
but if
anybody has any particular points they
want to make
certainly raise their hands and share a
couple of general questions
i'm looking on thank you um i'm looking
on page
one just one dark width okay and
um you know the bold phase italic
thing that changes for instance the
office may contract for services
investigators hearing officers leave up
so on and so forth a little further down
around line 19.
i guess my general question is
clearly these things were put in because
these provisions
weren't the case before they all seemed
like
rational changes to me can you give me a
little bit of background
so i can understand why these things
already weren't the case
it's my understanding that at one time
the various boards had
specific investigators to their boards
and what has happened of course is that
it's bloated
things where now this the way i read
this it
gives them the ability to not have to
have standing investigators
and they can bring in folks
rather than you're talking 15
53 almost 50 soon to be 54 boards here
that's
that's a tremendous amount of people if
every single board had its own
investigator
hi representative if i may mr chair
um having been on this committee for
many years and
been concerned
what happens in oplc the agile car
also many of these boards were
originally
autonomous little agencies around
concord
it was felt that if they were put under
one
main branch that particularly clerical
work
could be shared a lot of them had
clerical help that served part-time
and so it was felt that as an economy
measure
they could house them in one place and
have for example one
secretary will call that person
take care of the paperwork for more than
one board
so i hope that helps understanding of
how oplc came together with all these
and mr chairman lindsay courtney the
executive director
has joined us in the attendees i i
suspect she'd be
mr chair be sure you're speaking into
your microphone we could barely hear you
apologize i i clicked it off yes miss
courtney
if you would like to weigh in here on
senate bill 58
uh good morning mr chair members of the
subcommittee thanks for
the opportunity to speak and appear
before you today lindsey courtney
executive director
office of professional lace insurance
certification
yeah so this bill is really just a
cleanup bill from our perspective
um there are a number of things um when
the office was created
first of all i i disagree that there was
really there is a consensus about what
we're supposed to be doing here
versus versus the boards but um
but in any event it remains clear that
we haven't been able to
efficiently operate the office by virtue
of the fact that
um there remain um conflicting
provisions between oplc and the various
practice acts
so there are a number of things that we
attempted to clean up
i think it was last year in senate bill
576 and unfortunately
didn't go through because of covid um so
we essentially split up those two bills
this is a policy bill
really just designed to clean up and
further clarify
and permit the office to carry out the
efficient activities that it's required
to do
um the first being really establishing a
retention policy
the um this is really exactly this is a
problem that was really exacerbated by
the physical relocation of the office
which
um which wasn't done at the request of
the office i might
i might add it was quite expeditious
expedited
um and we had to move in a matter of
about 30 to 45 days
and we essentially have paper everywhere
and part of the problem is that the
board some boards have
a retention schedules that are approved
by a secretary of state
that conflict with each other for the
same types of records like disciplinary
versus licensing and we don't presently
have the authority to adopt
or promulgate a policy across the agency
um from our perspective a licensing file
should be treated the same regardless of
what profession it is and the same is
true for a
disciplinary file so so that was kind of
uh the gist of
a portion of this bill um are there
specific questions or do you want me to
just kind of walk
i mean are there specific questions i
already testified so i don't want to
go into great detail um but essentially
this is just
intended to be a cleanup measure and not
provide substantive
changes i think it would be more than
appropriate to
if folks have questions for you they're
directed at you to certainly do that
and that's the purpose of the
subcommittee so right representative
schmidt
thank you mr chairman uh well let me
begin by saying that i
uh agree with lindsay that uh this is
essentially a cleanup
uh and and trying to pull together uh
the the uh operations of oplc
in a more standardized form uh i think
one of the
one of the aspects is that the
investigative
capability of the boards uh was
it was you know kind of
hindered to some degree certainly by the
fact that
the boards were engaging frequently
their own
one of their own members uh to do
investigations well that person
might be very expert with regard to the
particular professions particularities
and peculiarities and so forth but the
person might not be
particularly skilled at investigative uh
or potentially prosecutorial aspects so
having somebody's
we we've heard from mr porter uh several
times
uh going into today's meeting uh with
regard to his function
you can see he's uh you know not only a
trained lawyer but also
a competent administrator uh so he
brings
that whole aspect in in a way that many
of the boards would not have had
personnel capable of doing that however
much they may have understood their own
professions
so the and oplc was intended
from the very beginning to be a support
uh
structure uh and standardization and so
forth everything that lindsay
just alluded to is correct so uh i
i think that having her give her a
bird's-eye view is helpful to people who
don't have the background that some of
us who've been on the committee for a
long time
uh bring to the table so i'm happy to
have her talk but
if if anybody has specific questions
let's have adam
representative thank you mr chair good
morning lindsay
um miss courtney sorry um
i'm curious if i assume you have spoken
with
a member of the various boards
particularly with
reference to retention of records and
i'm wondering if
areas of expertise for the various
professions
if there could perhaps be different
needs
for length of retention depending on the
board
and how much consideration was given to
those aspects
yeah i thank you representative um i
don't have an opinion on what the
retention
schedule should look like based on the
file type
um i think it's important from an
efficiency standpoint that we have one
or two different types of retention
schedules versus what we have now which
is
basically 54. um and we just can't
administratively support that
um i have spoken to a number of the
boards and the boards are are not
you know opposed to having a one
retention schedule
um i think they feel the same pain that
we have although they're not living in
you know they're not in the office so
they're not you know covered with files
um the boards do want to be
part of the process in terms of
determining what's appropriate and i
absolutely support that i'm not sure
that the subject matter really should
dictate
what uh you know in terms of there
should be board specific retention
schedules
you know licensing file is a licensing
file um regardless of what profession
um you are are a member of
um a physician licensing file will
certainly carry
different information versus like a
cosmetology licensing file but when we
think about the purpose of a board which
is to protect the public
you know that that whole purpose has to
weigh into the factors
in consideration if how long do we keep
this file um
and i don't really think that that's uh
suggestive or
i don't think that the subject matter of
the profession really should dictate
that
um i think we can easily come up with
some sort of agreement where a licensing
file is kept for
a certain period of time a disciplinary
file is kept for a certain period of
time
um maybe an inspection file is kept for
a certain period of time
um regardless of the profession but
obviously i welcome the board's thoughts
on that
um certainly as as we move forward
thank you and do you have a plan to um
i don't know meet with the various board
members to
hash this out with them yeah
it's quite um it's quite difficult i
think pursuing change in the office um
to some extent because
the boards don't always meet regularly
and essentially you have to go to 54
different board meetings and caucus
a number of board members we rely a lot
on our board administrators but also
most recently starting in april 1 we've
um we've been providing legal support at
every meeting for the entirety of the
meeting
um i have been communicating with all
board members on a quarterly basis via
letter because i want everybody to
receive the same amount of information
the same type of information at the same
time
um so i think our thought is we might
utilize the survey tool
to be perfectly honest um that might be
the fastest way of getting uh
feedback um we do have tools in-house
such as surveymonkey
uh to get that feedback from the boards
um because otherwise i think it's going
to take us forever to
move the ball forward you know even an
inch and we certainly need
um we need to we need to do a lot more
in a short period of time in terms of
establishing efficiencies
thank you i i definitely would encourage
uh
doing a poll such as that um i'm i'm
sure
aware that depending on the profession
there may be needs other than than what
you're looking at
if if one profession has a licensing
period of two years for their license
as opposed to those that have one year
obviously that would kind of require a
different retention period
if you're retaining them for seven years
for
a one year profession that's seven
rounds
but if it's a two-year profession that's
only three so
just just wanted to bear in mind that
that could be a need
and it should be explored so thank you
oh you're welcome and on that point
representative i would just note
we um from my perspective we need to
retain the licensure file for the
entirety that somebody is licensed
and then the question is really how long
after the person is no longer licensed
do you retain the files so um
i think that would be something that the
boards would need to consider
some have um you know seven years after
a person is deceased i mean that's a
very long time
um but then others are you know 10 years
after they are no longer licensed so
that's really what we're looking at
for those that that are not overly
familiar oplc
is really in its infancy as a as an
organization
so you know some of these boards are
still going through a little bit of a
growing pain
if you will because they they did
operate autonomously for
for a very long time
know as as we all try to find
ways in state government to not only
make things more efficient but more cost
effective
you know i i can understand how they're
still
you know some of these boards are still
holding on a little bit to
the ways of the past and you know that's
certainly a struggle that
you you obviously do on a daily basis
here so
you know the basically you know the
first two pages of the bill
kind of give the broad you know the
broad spectrum and authority that
that the office needs to have
here um and then the rest of this bill
it just really kind of does the minutia
of
hitting each individual board and
you know what what is either repealed or
brought in to
streamline this and i'm you know i've
certainly not received any specific
objections
from specific boards at least
at least to me as the chair of the
subcommittee and i would imagine that
you know their standard procedure at
this point would be to bring them
through you
so you know if you have any that you're
that you're dealing with that you need
to bring forward violence do so but
um the other thing i want to touch on
before i go to representative schmidt
is there was some discussion in the in
the general hearing
when it came to the premium compensation
of the boards and i
just want to i highlighted this and i
just want to point out that you know on
page two
line six where section three is the rate
of predictive compensation for all
boards
basically will be will be set by oplc
um which which makes sense to me what
that doesn't say
is that it's all going to be the same
and i would presume that you still are
going to retain
discretion as to what the per diem
compensation is
for specific boards based on and i hate
to use the word value of time
but certain professions do inherently
have a
greater value of time so i would presume
that that's
you're still operating that way that
you're gonna the premiums will be looked
at individually
yes absolutely so right now um
i think you're totally correct uh
representative in that um the per diem
rates shouldn't be
the same um what we'd like to do is make
sure that every board member is
receiving a per diem
not all boards receive a per diem the
majority of technical boards don't
receive anything at all
um and so we want to make um give give
all board members a per diem
and then obviously look at the amount of
time that's where that's required in
order to be a board member
one of the things that we're currently
doing in the office is a reassessment of
our staff
um to representative um schuett's point
a lot of our
staff have historically been part-time
which has been a barrier to achieving
efficiencies so
um you probably noted in the budget that
we requested a reduction of our
part-time staff and
an increase in our full-time staff but
what we're doing right now with the
division of personnel is
essentially doing a reassessment of our
staff and the first step of is really
classifying the boards
based on um basically the amount of time
that's involved in both administering
the boards and being a board member
using
you know quantifiable metrics so i
imagine that we'll use some sort of tool
like that
to propose different structures for per
diems um
and then obviously seek the board's
input as previously discussed through
through surveys and whatnot what we want
to avoid
is unclear expectations
and in in make sure that we have
sufficient amount of appropriations but
also make clear
as to um when a board member is entitled
to
per dam and when when they may not be so
also too just a reminder
the the compensation for the board
members comes out of the fees and it's
not
is not coming from taxpayer money
correct yes correct correct
representative thank you um thank you mr
chairman
so i might turn my camera back on um
one of the issues we've already spoken
about a little bit this morning is the
retention of records
uh and i think while it's uh
nice to be able to go back 10 or 15
years
with regard to somebody who may have
been a member of a particular profession
a licensed
member one of the the
problems in doing so is if you have
paper records which is of course
what everybody had for a long long time
at some point you
i will start to literally kind of
suffocate
in the the sheer quantity of
uh of paperwork that you have in boxes
or stacked here and there and everywhere
can you speak to that
a little bit more specifically uh miss
courtney uh
because i i think that's something that
the new members may not
quite recognize that uh that you are in
smaller quarters than you were uh like
uh
i was very familiar with the offices
over at philbrook
uh that you had previously and i believe
you've
you've been reduced to what uh maybe
a third or fourth quarter quarter of the
uh the space you had before which was
not
it's not like you were work working
inside the
los angeles coliseum uh but you had a
lot more space before and
the retention of records is uh is a real
problem
if you're if you're uh having to deal
with a lot less space
thank you representative yes we have
reduced our space by about six thousand
square feet which is about a third of
what we had previously out of philbrook
um
has become a significant concern for the
office
we have begun a push um to move every
all licensing online
and all renewals are now online
thankfully um
and so the idea is that if we can at
least stop
the flow of paper we can deal with what
we have which is a significant amount of
paper
um all um initial licensing should be
online by
august of 2022 so that's a goal that we
have and
it looks we're moving in that direction
pretty nicely
we have started a scanning project where
we've been working with
the bureau of graphic services to scan
in all of our
old documentation and what we're dealing
with now is how do we manage that we
don't
yet have a document management system um
that interfaces with our licensing
portal
and so that's something that we're going
to be looking to hopefully acquire
after we obtain a budget um
but to your point yes we're retaining
records
essentially indefinitely and when we
moved from philbrook
um we had to clean out that storage shed
that was in the back and
we have records dating back to you know
the 30s the 20s
it's it's it's really um problematic in
terms of just
managing paper um and being able to
retrieve information
um right just getting at this stuff
uh becomes a real problem when you've
got stuff that's literally
buried at the bottom of a pile yeah it's
kind of like
trying to remove the bottom figure on a
totem pole
yes it reminded me of cleaning out my
you know grandparents house
i'm not gonna lie speaking as somebody
was as
probably as old as your grandparents uh
i i know that uh that phenomenon very
well
um but one one thing that should be
referenced in our discussions this
morning is the fact that
uh that that some of the records uh
especially the board of psychology
records uh where confidentiality
is is key um and having records
uh that could fall into the wrong hands
um is is a real issue when you're
talking about
mental health aspects where uh the the
client's privacy
uh is essential um many of the records
you're dealing with in other professions
are but
completely different nature uh and so
disposing of them
uh the physical records anyway once they
are
uh perhaps you know as you say scanned
in
uh it's a different matter entirely so
thank you
yes i wouldn't advocate for retaining
paper records forever but
uh you must have sought some state-owned
storage space that where you can you
know move the older files
scoring yeah we do have some storage
um space off-site through the department
of admin services
um state space space is at a premium um
right
now it's hard to come by i believe we
have records in the walker building
we also have a lot of
not records but equipment uh furniture
that are is
presently being stored on a truck that
we're renting um
until we can figure out how to um
basically uh dispose of that that
equipment um so we do um and we have
looked into
securing a storage space and independent
storage space
it's not it's not um financially a
burden um
but it's more of a burden to actually
physically maintain all the files in an
appropriate format so that they're
easily accessible
thank you so fantastic so that you know
that
that pretty much covers the the opening
general part of this
like i said the rest of this bill is all
just individual
uh changes to the boards to get them in
line
and like i said i i don't i haven't seen
any
objections but i'll i'll let
representative goalie pipe up here
and see what he has to say
thank you mr chair um i noticed there's
a lot of
repeals in this bill
and i mean that that concerns me when
you go down line by line looking at
some of the things that are being
repealed i think we need to take a
closer look
and make sure that really need to be
repealed
we're not hearing from the boards on
them which concerns me
um and i'll start just from the first
section of repeals i look at
in the page bottom of page five
and i don't know if miss courtney could
help me out here
um we're repealing uh under the
um alcohol and other drug use
professionals hearings
section uh repealing uh section relative
the rules for the conduct of hearings
and relative to retaining experts in
investigations or hearings
amended the bill that dealt with
hearings recently and we
we're pretty specific in that the boards
will retain the right
to the hearings and ask for an
investigator if necessary
um so i want to know how repealing these
thank you representative i just want to
look at that so
as a as a just an overall matter um
this bill was part of a larger bill that
i tried to basically cut in half and it
was written
it was drafted when the investigations
bill was essentially one that would
create
one um investigations set of rules
um and really the gist of that is
because it's very difficult to operate
under
54 or 55 different sets of rules
specific to latex let me take a look at
that i can tell you why we're repealing
uh mileage is because we'd like to put
that in rule
not all boards have uh entitlement to
mileage and some boards only have
entitlement mileage so we think that's
better
placed in rules so that it can cover all
boards and when you need to change
something you're just changing it once
instead of 54 different times
um regarding uh line 37 relative to
retaining experts for investigations or
hearings
it's our um understanding of working
with doj is that the boards no longer
have the authority to retain to enter
into contracts that the contracting is
done through the office of professional
lace intern certification
so certainly they can still retain
experts but it has to be through the
office so they're not actually
going out and making payments they no
longer have their budgets
um
specific to number nine um roman numeral
nine let me just take a look at that
because that could be an area
uh so
miss courtney if you have it please give
us the line number and page number
and roman numeral
9 procedures for the conduct of hearings
consistent with the requirements of due
process
yeah so this was drafted when we were
hopefully planning to obtain legislation
that would permit us to
to just have one set of hearings rules
for all boards
um certainly if you want to strike that
out in light of their
recent statutory amendments that would
make sense to me um but that was
the that was the basis for for those
changes
so that this doesn't affect what we're
doing in the other
piece of legislation that's going
forward i don't think it affects it no
i i mean but this repeal would certainly
remove
at least from the alcohol and drug
statute practice act
the ability for the board to promulgate
rules regarding hearings
the understanding was in the previous
piece of legislation that the boards
could do the hearings and ask for an
investigator if necessary
taking out this making rules for
hearings
eliminates that from them correct and we
didn't want to do that is that correct
yeah that's correct so in light of the
stack in light of the amendment that the
that the committee um approved you know
you may want to change that so that
we're not repealing um
page 5 line 36 um
i mean again our perspective is that
it's it's incredibly difficult to have
so many sets of rules that are
procedural in nature
and that's really the gist of hearings
rules is
the rules are centered on when you file
a motion when you file a pleading how
long you have to respond
they're not substantive in nature and so
from our perspective there really is no
reason why you need to have 56 different
sets of rules but
um but certainly to to in line with um
the committee's recommendations
regarding that amendment you may want to
eliminate that repeal thank you mr
chairman could you make note that we may
want to
i did like that like and you know on top
of that miss courtney so
if that's the case under the alcohol
and other drug professionals do we find
this exact repeal
anywhere else i mean you know what i
mean because we're looking at
one group actually you know the second
the second group in here
is does this occur does this occur in
other parts
um most likely um i see it in
317a which is cosmetology on page 11.
um i see it on
page 11 line 36 regarding 326h i think
it's dietitians
so i mean what i could do uh
representative is i could go through and
propose an amendment that would
eliminate
um the repeals regarding hearings
if that would if that would be helpful
to you sure that
because we're looking we're gonna need
someone to do a deep dive here into
where that's located in
in all the various sports because
because again if we're if we're
establishing this to streamline and be
consistent
then any amendment brought forward would
have to be streamlined and consistent
yes mr chair if i may
suggest i'm i'm thinking in terms of
engaging investigators and i'm wondering
if
back on page one if the
line that says the office may contract
for the services of
hearing officers legal counsel and
experts
as necessary if we inserted before the
words
as necessary perhaps in consultation
with the appropriate board
would that be acceptable
ms courtney i assume that you would be
doing that
anyway but i think uh perhaps
members of our committee might be more
comfortable with that wording included
yeah i would have no problem with that
you just make a note
representative you said various boards
maybe appropriately in consul
in consultation with the appropriate
board in other words if they're engaging
an investigator
for cosmetology
applicants they would consult with that
board obviously to
to be sure that the investigator that
they are considering
is something that that board is kind of
miss courtney in your experience and i
know you've been with those plc
for a brief time here would
would the request for an investigation
typically come from
a board or would it come from the oplc
office itself
that's something that we're still trying
to work through um historically the
boards have
basically started investigations i can
tell you
from my perspective i have concerns with
that idea because
um and i've shared this and we've talked
about it openly with the boards and
legal counsel
because one of the issues that we're
running into is is um
whether or not there are perceived
violations of due process but or actual
violations of due process
when boards are intimately involved in
the actual investigative process it's
very hard for them
to to at least remain um or create the
perception that they are a neutral body
that is also the adjudicating body
so when you think of boards the boards
are the judge so should the board also
be the police officer and the prosecutor
no but that's essentially the the
statutory um
authority and the framework that's been
created for them
and so what we've tried to do um working
with collaborative
collaboratively with the boards is try
to like silo that process
either to have a board member who's kind
of like reviewing complaints and making
recommendations and or assisting with
the rois
and just bringing the reports of
investigation to the board for decision
making
but there are a lot a number of boards
that still insist on being intimately
involved with the investigations process
i can understand that that you're in the
you're in the old line of
you know who's guarding the guards here
great it becomes it becomes
circular in a way right i definitely see
your point with that
on the other hand some profession so
detailed that
only someone who has done that work
may know the ins and outs of of
certainly agree representative which is
why i think we need it we have
um we're trying to set up a framework
where we pair experts we retain them as
necessary or we request board members to
utilize their expertise
while at the same time preserving on the
neutrality of the
the board that's actually going to be
voting
thank you mr chairman uh so uh
as some of us will recall that's one of
the problems that we've had with
uh the um with
the uh oversight of
of daycare centers uh that
some of the licensees have brought up
real problems with the idea that that
the
agency is a judge jury and executioner
uh and so uh
that is as representative was just
pointing out
it's difficult when you have something
that's very detailed
that only professionals would easily
understand
and have any background in uh by the
same token
the judge jury and executioner thing
just lends itself to
uh to potential abuses
and authoritarianism on the part of some
practitioners
of uh some uh oversight
agencies but maybe
not having that particular issue in
statute
in this bill at this time until
until the oplc has worked out
some kind of a balancing act where you
have neither the in neither of the
extremes
uh included i i think that's something
that we
i think that's where we're headed and
not trying to put that in statute at
this point
where we haven't quite worked out how
we're going to do it
thank you representative schmidt
representative allegro yeah i
agree with that and uh i actually would
even expand upon it i think it's a
critical issue because not only
can a board be or any agent be a judge
during an executioner but
they set the rules to the plaintiffs to
the investigator
and then they're the judge jury and
executioner as well
and also too as we saw last term
there was there was a significant amount
of concern brought forward in the world
of
that that i don't think is
super unique to that one particular
group
so so i i do agree that having having
that a bit of separation there
for the sake of due process really does
matter
and also too you know we're talking
about investigations of
when you get to the point of bringing in
investigators we've had a substantial
violation here a substantial problem and
that
should should be if it you know for the
point of investigators
should be obvious to someone that is
more than just a technical expert
if you know if you're looking at an
egregious act
that a board would would say we need to
take action and investigate this
you should be able to convince me of
that
a subject matter expert this isn't a
matter of you know did i use a 90 degree
elbow
elbow and a plumbing fitting instead of
a 45 you know we wouldn't
you wouldn't elevate that to that sort
of level so
these are these are acts that that
should
when when brought forward should make
sense to to lay people to a point
well that's what that's that's why
having mr porter as part of the process
where he has experience in
investigations
and administration from that end of
things because there is going to be some
uniformity
in in investigations above and beyond
that
the highly technical things that you
might have in some professions
so it's a it's a balancing act and it's
very difficult
that's why i'm suggesting and i think
we're heading in the direction of
of excluding that from this bill so that
we're not
jumping off the diving board before
we're sure whether there's any water in
the pool
representative
remind the committee that there was uh
in senate bill
133 section 7 was the
authority of the office of professional
licensure and certification for
administration of rulemaking and
enforcement of investigations hearings
and appeals
the subcommittee did a thorough vetting
of that bill and working with
tom broderick miss courtney and
amended the bill and came back with a
final pro
product that i think we were happy with
so
um as we continue to talk about
investigations hearings and appeals that
was already part of
uh senate bill 133 yeah and i think that
that's certainly your justification for
for removing that part out of this bill
we don't want to if that's already been
worked out we don't want to
cause certainly don't want to cause
confusion in the statute
correct so so no i i have no
i certainly have no issue with that i
again if it's been addressed in another
bill there's
there's no point in doing it here so
but i think you know i think we've
covered certainly covered that aspect of
it
do you either right
just confirming just confirming
representative goldie's remarks
uh i'm i'm recalling that specific
aspect so that is something that we were
happy
with the uh this solution we'd worked
out
is uh mr broderick on this call
i don't see him no he's not he's not on
he's on another
um we're trying to provide legal support
to all the boards right now and uh
i know spread a little bit activating a
little bit i just got off a lancer here
so
i'm i'm just uh mindful of what
representative gold
just said i would hope that you and he
would
take a a good look at uh this bill
to see if there are conflicts such as
that
that we can wipe from this bill so that
we're only concentrating on
one yeah absolutely that's what we'll do
we'll go through the bill and we'll make
sure it's consistent with the amendment
that was put forth by
uh the committee regarding 133 right
i do um if if we could get some clarity
on
um on page one line seven the office may
contract for the services of
investigators hearing officers legal
counsel and experts as necessary i
assume that
we still want to keep that in but just
make that modification
um to be in consultation with the boards
yes
mr chair yes
um i also have as we go down looking at
the
things that are being repealed a few
questions on some of these issues as we
go further down the bill if i may ask
some questions on those later on
on page eight line
eight um under allied health
relative to rule making by the allied
health board of directors
um why are they not i'm not sure what
they what's going on there and why
that's being repealed
why why are they no longer allowed to
um thank you i we're not removing all
rule making capabilities
let me just cross-reference it um
[Music]
it would just be rules regarding fees
um rules regarding um
hold on the design and content of
application forms
um i think we subsequently make clear
that the boards retain the
authority over eligibility requirements
procedures forms and fees for temporary
licensure
and procedures for receipt of misconduct
complaints so this would be one of those
that as we go through
we would probably um modify
to not repeal 328 f13 roman numeral two
regarding the
receipt of misconduct of complaints so
start with
three to five instead of two to five yes
exactly
uh if i may mr chair i think um
ms courtney had said that she's going to
go through and
and re-examine all of the repeals
uh with reference to those specific
areas
and i it's appearing that we're going to
need
another meeting bill to deal with those
to
be able to put forward a cohesive
amendment
right and and not having tom uh
broderick involved in this process today
is
uh i understand he can't be in two
places at one time
but since he is uh certainly the uh
the mechanic if you will that is uh
doing the work on this
uh it's imperative to have his
involvement in it
so i agree that we're gonna probably
need a second session
yeah absolutely tom um we can get time
involved absolutely i was the one who
drafted this bill and i drafted it
133 so i've drafted them all pretty much
so so i've
been um more than happy to also
participate but we can certainly get
tom's involvement as well
well i i i it's good that in in a sense
that you've been involved in the
drafting it means you do understand
uh what's what's been done by the same
token as executive director
uh your time is precious with regard to
being the director and not not a
mechanic as well
thank you representative so we we are
going to have to be mindful of some
deadlines here
with this because we we have we are
approaching
this month while we're thinking about
this maybe i can
mention just one other aspect which
hasn't been discussed this morning
uh back in the early days of uh of
uh representative mcguire's time in the
in the house and on this committee
uh there were a lot of repeals that were
in one of the bills
uh and it was pointed out by some of the
agencies that
uh that that some of the requirements
that were being repealed or some of the
statutes
that were being repealed were the
underpinning for
uh some of the structures that uh that
had been created
and by repealing them you were kind of
tearing the basement out of the building
uh and uh so those repeals were
were withdrawn because they would have
erect the uh
the uh the legitimacy and the structure
of the of the agency so that probably is
not the case here too much but
uh we need to be mindful of that as well
as you have invoked the name of our
chair
representative mcguire if she
to uh chair i'm glad to hear that you're
looking at this
in such detail and coordinating it with
i'd also like to remind you to take a
look at the amendment
that courtney presented
and the deadline for this bill is
27 yes the 27th
so that that's that's the deadline to
we have a finished amendment yes yes so
sounds like it's going to be necessary
yeah i agree
so our major concern is is basically
fitting another subcommittee in uh to
accommodate
staff that needs to facilitate
a remote meetings such as this
what i schedule next week
tuesday and thursday and the following
tuesday
you can i believe that there are plenty
of openings that week
week of the eighth of monday would be
the 17th
so you can say it's convenient for the
subcommittee
okay yeah i'm showing we're already
we're already booked for the 18th
um we have a
uh an executive session that pays for as
many
you know start at two o'clock or
something and uh
i'll have another uh final exact session
or you can you can get another day
there's no it doesn't seem there's much
competition for licenses
okay you're gonna remind that this is
the subcommittee so you only need a
24-hour notice
yeah right right you can go
you can go for a monday mondays are
it would be good just to to avoid the
24-hour notice if at all possible
if you can get it in the calendar it's
definitely a preferred
way to go yeah we would pam at the
earliest we
would this would be the week of the 16th
so
okay great mr chair um representative
mcguire's audio was breaking
to me did i understand her to say that
she had
forwarded an amendment on this bill to
the committee members
and we have that um is was there a
numbered amendment
or what date should we look for that on
i found an amendment from senator carson
um 1153
s it to senate bill 58 is that the one
you're referring to representative
mcguire
no although that one needs to be
considered as well
this one i sent it to
uh i received it from this courtney
as a she wanted to
put it into one tree but i thought it
was more
christmas applicable to senate bill 58
so i sent it
out to the committee for that i will
uh step away when i finish talking to
you also find it
and send it to you thank you
it was to eliminate the requirements
that board
members physically sign a license
there's a nuisance and i can't see
okay yeah
i think i do recall seeing that
amendment
i remember seeing it i i'm not finding
it right now
and i'm looking for it i've got the
carson amendment to senate bill 58
that i just made copies of and i can
bring down to you and i just sent it to
everybody but
the other amendment i'm not finding
i it seems like i remember seeing
something about signing but
amendment that's what it is it's a draft
oplc amendment that's what i have
yeah if you can bring those down that
would be great i
hmm
now as far as as far as the removing of
the physical physical signature part of
this
it is it is in fact 2021
and the ability to to handle things
digitally
certainly exists and you know that's
with this this outdated requirement
really
time times are such that you know all
you're really doing with these
signatures is just
just affirming the things are in fact
valid
and that honestly the oplc would be
doing that anyway if things were called
into question
difficult
[Music]
um
okay
do you see one representative fire for
senate bill 133
that was that was just kind of a
statement as to
as to one of the one of the emails that
we did receive
[Music]
so you have the two amendments one
official from senator carson and one
unofficial
i just i just resent it to be committed
so it should be out there for anybody
who's looking
oh i i didn't get that i didn't get an
email from the carol little
um yeah but we have a physical it looks
oh i don't know that's odd that i didn't
get it
should be on that list
i guess i'm not on that i'm not on that
all right well we can uh if uh
representative schuett
and representative schmidt have have
that we can
we can certainly take up senator
i apologize mr chair someone was at my
door were they delivering an amendment
to you
so wonderfully the amendment
says okay so to insert section one of
the bill
so we're looking at 310 2a which i
believe
it's
[Music]
okay so what has changed in this
amendment is
the bottom part of the italicized where
it says
rules for pharmacists and pharmacy
technicians licensed by the pharmacy
board
shall include requirements for training
and experience regarding pharmacy laws
pharmacy
and it's extraordinarily specific
unfortunately senator carson's not here
with us to give us context miss courtney
are you
do you understand the context of this
yes okay help us out here thank you mr
chair
so um this came about essentially at the
request of representative merchant
who had expressed concerns regarding the
original bill as drafted that was
presented in the senate
the concern um was basically um
that we have three investigators here
who are employed by oplc who assist the
board of pharmacy
in a number of states i've moved in the
direction of utilizing non-pharmacists
or non-pharmacy technicians to conduct
inspections for pharmacy
which um both the pharmacy board myself
and representative merchant agree is not
conducive to protecting public safety um
and so
uh representative merchant and the board
wanted to make clear
that and you know in the event i leave
and somebody else isn't
responsible for hiring that the statute
mandated that
um that the inspectors uh for pharmacy
actually have the requisite experience
in pharmacy um
as opposed to um law enforcement
officers as other states have used
okay i can understand that but what then
why why would this be put into the
general part of this and not
under the statute where under
one of you know this would be page 26
under
pharmacy board so
um i apologize because i don't have the
actual amendment in front of me
um the one that i'm looking at says
amend section 104 of the bill by
replacing page 25 lines 30 through 34
with the following
pharmacy board inspection shall be
provided by pharmacists or pharmacy
technicians licensed by the new
hampshire board of pharmacy who have
training and experience regarding
privacy statutes and rules
yeah that's a different that's the
second half of this amendment
okay but what what i read was the first
half of this amendment
that is inserting this into rather than
inserting it into the pharmacy board
part of it it inserts it into
basically under administration of the
office
yeah i think the only reason
justification i can offer
is that there's a there's a general
disconnect
the staff are employed by the office i
think that that's still
something that um boards have a concern
with that they don't have direct reports
they don't have direct staff
and this has come up in the context of
pharmacy because
technically the pharmacists who are
conducting inspections don't work for
the pharmacy board
and they can be conducting inspections
and do conduct inspections um
in other professions um like veterinary
medicine
and whatnot so by virtue of that because
they're actually staff
and not specific to pharmacy i think it
could go in the general administration
um just to make it super clear that
these types of staff
should have this requisite information
um training education experience
we could certainly limit it to 318 9a
regarding inspectional services
um but i can envision a scenario where
we're using a pharmacist staff member to
do something that's not
you know not specific to to 318.
i mean you have to live with this so
that's that's why i'm asking
yeah and honestly this was just a
compromise
i mean we didn't draft it with this
language because we didn't think it was
necessary because
because i i completely agree that and
by virtue of the supplemental job
descriptions we're not allowed to hire
law enforcement officers
or anybody that doesn't have the
requisite experience
but this is essentially a compromise
because
you know just to make sure that the
pharmacy board was comfortable with this
language
so if this is what they were comfortable
with and i'm happy to
i think it's i think it's fine i don't
think it's necessary but i think it's
fine
can i just interject um and just so you
know
miss courtney i just emailed you the
amendment
so so you can see it
in real life and i i'm listening to the
discussion but looking at the
amendment that the sentence added to the
first section on line
seven through nine of the amendment and
it doesn't refer to inspections it just
refers to
technicians that are licensed
so it seems kind of disconnected from
the second one
yeah i agree it should probably be
changed to reflect that it's
um staff who conduct
inspections yeah i think that would
would would help everybody yeah this is
right as i've read this that's why
that's why i asked if it was appropriate
to be in this section because it's
yeah it seems it doesn't seem like it
has anything to do with
inspections it talks about pharmacy tax
yeah yeah i can certainly make that um
propose change and get that back to the
committee
so look looking at the bottom half
and i'll the amendment i'll give you a
chance to bring that up
this this does refer to section 104
which
in fact in the bill is relative to
pharmacy boards
so
again that's this is also adding a
sentence
at the bottom that's the change the
upper the first part of italicized is
already there
so this the addition here is
similar to above where it is the last
sentence
pharmacy board inspections shall be
provided by pharmacists or pharmacy
technicians licensed by the new
hampshire pharmacy board
okay so is this not is this just not
repeating oh are we looking at
redundancy here
so it sounds to me like the first part
of this doesn't need to exist
i would agree with that i mean
because in essence if you're if you're
changing the first section of this
to what we just talked about you're just
just creating language that it
started at the bottom yeah
i i i agree um i don't think it needs to
be there
so we can we can just do away with the
top half of this yeah
sense
does anybody have any questions on the
okay fantastic so moving on now to the
now this is that what ms smarling just
resent to us
also oplc amendment
um mike representative mcguire if you're
if you're still there this this says
amendment to senate bill 133
so i is it fair to presume that this is
that's what i'm seeing also and that
that was my concern that
um we're into issues that are
contained in 133 also and i think we
need to be careful
that we're not we we've overlapped
well exactly and that and representative
goalie's already brought that up that
we're
you know where we can't we can't bring
two bills forward
that in essence are covering the same
area right yeah it's gonna become
problematic so
so i guess once we get representative
mcguire back we can find out if this is
because that's what i mean it literally
says amendment to senate bill 133 on it
right
yeah i thought she had said that it was
drafted as an amendment to senate bill
133 but she felt it was more
appropriate to senate bill 58
but i could certainly be wrong
so just so that while we're waiting on
that looking through this
um the first page is signed and dated by
the chairperson we have
signed by members signed by members side
by members this is
this is uh hand sealed signed by members
okay so what this is what this is doing
i mean since we have the time and
regardless of whether it's 58 or 133
we're all gonna be
we're all gonna be looking at it anyway
this seems to be
consistently across the board removing
the requirement of physical
being struck out that's that's
i agree mr chair if i can point out uh
representative mcguire lives fairly
close to me
it is extremely windy here i
assume it is where she is although so
she may be having electrical issues
yeah clear clearly she was having
internet issues when she
she addressed us earlier but i mean this
i'm just following this email chain from
that representative mcguire sent out
attached to this email
um and i don't know if miss courtney
wants to
talk to us about this this originally
came from her to represent mcguire
representative scitec
and then was forwarded to p.m and you it
wondering if it was jermaine to 58
versus 133
so i don't know if we want to hear from
either pm or miss courtney on them who
are
attachment happy to speak to it um this
is an issue that has come up
um recently
um by virtue of the fact that um
uh you know we've we're trying to move
to an electronic platform
and um it's very difficult for us to
physically
keep capturing board members electronic
signatures i'm not even sure if that's
appropriate
or consistent with the statutory
requirements that exist as you see in
front of you
so i had reached out to representative
mcguire regarding this amendment
this is completely certificates i
believe are separate from what's in 133
and 58
um so i have reached out regarding 133
from my perspective i think it could go
in 58 i think it can go in 133
um but um it's a slowly it's a slowly
separate issue regarding certificates
only
mr chair yes i guess my
question would be either to you or to pm
is this considered
germaine to this bill or non-germain
yeah i think you know what my sense of
it was since
58 is relative to the administration of
the oplc
and this is clearly to me it's an
administrative
feature that it it is germane i mean i
i'm not the
the you know the only one who can
weigh in on germaness but from my sense
it
it fit in with with 58. okay thank you
that may be why representative mcguire
stated what she did in reference to this
being more appropriate to 58
because because this this clearly is
just an administrative
change but that's you know that's all
this
it's just striking out the the
requirement for and again too you know
we're talking about streamlining and
consistency here
if we're going to go to electronic
records
we need to go to electronic signatures i
mean i know
it would seem weird to me that we would
maintain databases of electronic records
and then have to have a random piece of
that doesn't that doesn't seem to jive
what we're trying to i very much agree
mr chair one more question to miss
courtney if i may absolutely
uh in the email the initial email to
that went out
with this amendment uh you mentioned
senate bill 13
that this language was part of and
didn't move forward could you give us a
little more insight as to what
that was yeah 13 um it's a senate bill
that um pertains primarily only
to fee so to be honest with you i'm not
sure why when i was drafting this
i included in 13 um when i went back and
i'm like oh
probably shouldn't have done that um 13
basically
um was the person at 576 that removed
the provisions from the practice acts
that granted the boards the authority to
promulgate fees
and or created statutory fees because if
you recall 310a
theoretically grants to the office the
ability to promulgate fees
but uh the boards have retained that
authority in their practice act so
that's that cleanup portion
and it went to uh senate ways and means
and it's
just kind of hung out there i i don't
know if they're going to try to tack it
on to hp2 if they're just going to
you know lay it on the table i don't
know what they're going to do with that
so all right thank you
if i'm hearing you correctly the this
amendment here that removes the
electronic signature part was sent to
ways it means
yeah because it was it was tied up
within
the fee bill i i don't know why i
drafted it mr chair that
in that way um i have to say it was very
difficult i think to split the bill
um and so it was just a drafters error
to be honest with you
um it was tied up in a fees bill so
okay i wasn't aware that the fee
structure of oplc
would never go to ways and means
that just in specular to me since edna
has
the responsibility of completely dealing
with overdancing
um mr chair um
if if we are going to incorporate
this draft amendment into senate bill 58
um i think rather than
i haven't gone through to see if
all the language for well i'll just pick
one
um well the one that i'm looking at uh
section 329 colon 14.
action on license applications
two of the draft amendment
rather than incorporate all of this
language to just
show that we're striking that one line
if we could incorporate these pieces
under those headings and just show the
line that's being deleted
i think that would simplify things and
one thing that i would point out
in this specific section uh this is
probably for miss
courtney especially um
stating that the license the
the way it's lined out it doesn't make
sense in that specific sentence
i think it needs to say stating this
grammatical
radical problem yeah i think it says
like
this shall state that the licensee is
authorized
okay it's it's a little bit funky the
way um
yeah the ing was struck out but
it's a little hard to read but um i
think it works
okay yeah your strikeout kind of at
least in my copy kind of
found its way over to the e so
yeah i'm just saying if if all of the
i mean the huge paragraphs are included
here to show the lines struck out
to show the context but if we don't have
that entire paragraph in this
bill i'm just saying perhaps we don't
need to
incorporate all these paragraphs because
that's going to make this bill even
larger
yeah i think ols would just do the
paragraphs they would just break out
i think i think um miss courtney you
know just
wanted to give you the full context yeah
yeah
most of this is just the paragraph with
the exception of maybe
the second to last one and the one that
represented
i haven't found all of them yet so some
of them it is
and we would need the paragraph right
yeah
yeah for example on unlike the first one
328 f i think if it just included
uh roman numeral four and then obviously
if you're striking a b would just be
renumbered to become
yeah as long as the ls is happy with
that yeah i think that's all that would
need to be
put forward as as the amendment to this
bill
i think like i said i'm still looking
through trying to find all the sections
i would imagine too with the on the on
the
third page section the 151 part where
where part three is struck out that
four would become three yeah
that one that would also i mean there
there is there is pieces of statue where
where there are roman numeral lines and
they just say repealed on them
i mean that does exist so right that's
what
i'm saying i don't know that we need to
have all this other
language the rest of it just seemed the
rest of it all just seems to be parts of
sentences so
yeah those are in those two particular
locations
i'm sure that's fine you know
but i don't i is there any is there any
other is any objections to
what we're doing here with this it seems
pretty straight forward to me
you know again we're the focus of of
oh no we're we're doing a lot of good
stuff here
so beyond that another suggestion i
would have
i have gone through the bill previously
and noticed in several places
um and i've i don't know that i've
got all of them but um
i'm trying to find some of my little
quick notes
for example page 10
[Music]
um
down under repeals chiropractic
um number four 40 uh line 21
um i'm sorry wrong line lines
a true record of all their official acts
shall be made and preserved
and it did say by the board's executive
director
and that's chained to office of
professional licensure
so on and so forth that exists in dozens
of locations throughout the stock right
exactly that's my point and i'm just
saying
retention policy established by the
office
and i'm wondering if we should include
that language that we discussed
in the very first page about
in consultation with the appropriate
board
the only problem is that at this point
with this
what happens if you have three boards
that don't like it
or three boards that want to retain this
or not well my point is that some boards
may feel the need to retain things
longer
miss courtney did say that there could
be possibly two or three
different retention periods agreed to
and i would hope that in her
polling of the boards that she would be
able to
align those accordingly so that you
would end up with only
possibly two or three different
retention periods
so that i just bring it up because like
i said i did go through the bill before
we started
a few days ago actually and and loaded a
few of those places
in this case in order for that to work
that would the oplc
would have to would have to do this
statutorily
i don't think that we need to handcuff
that i think that miss courtney's office
should shouldn't be just handling that
through through the authority we give
them
all right i just like i said i just put
that forward because the thought had
occurred to me when i was
originally going through the bill
is there any other parts of senate bill
58 that are
in need of discussion beyond the
marching orders we've given to miss
courtney
the
[Music]
changes that we've outlined in the two
amendments
we have no attendees with hands up and
we
we're under the tone of silence with the
rest of us so if that's the case then
then i will close the subcommittee
hearing on senate bill 58
and we will resume at one o'clock
for senate bill 104
with um and just for those that for
those of you at home
uh senate bill 104 doesn't does have two
amendments
one from senator carson and one from
representative mcguire that we'll be
addressing along with mr chairman if i
might
i received a call from senator reagan a
while back maybe somebody else did as
well
uh i believe he is going to be
unavailable for this afternoon
oh i don't know what that's all about
it's uh it's on high and are you hearing
me now we are
yeah yes okay so
senator reagan is going to be
unavailable this afternoon
and he's asked me to speak to the
subcommittee with regard to
how the jc represents and uh represent
is representative roy going to
is he with us this morning he
was represented roy represent
is currently on the on the jc ec
with me and representing scitec was on
previously to representative roy so
they're they're members of many who are
knowledgeable
okay yeah we'll uh we'll be happy to go
through this at one o'clock
great just to alert the committee that
senator reagan will not be there
that's okay thank you it must be very
windy and over because watching you is
kind of like watching a foreign movie
in subtitles because you're your lips
so well with that with that fam if you
want to throw uh if you want to throw
the notice up
that uh chair yes excuse me um
i have uh amendment 1202
for 104 do you have is there a number
for the second amendment
yep it's uh 11.95 thank you very much
all right i'll i'll mute the room and
you'll just need to remember to unmute
um when one o'clock comes around
uh
[Music]
all right so i've unmuted us now thank
you
up
[Music]
okay
it is one o'clock so we are going to get
underway with senate bill
open the subcommittee meeting
as a refresher senate bill 104 is
adopting anonymous legislation relative
to the classification of state employee
positions
and reverse auctions i don't i don't
believe
we're going to be auctioning off state
employees here but
the first part of this bill is relative
to classifications within
state employee positions this is
deleting
[Music]
six physicians all within the department
of health and human services
and it is it's establishing
[Music]
eight eight positions
and mr chairman if i might just
interject um
commissioner commissioner arlinghaus is
here and and he certainly
um works closely with the joint
committee on employee classifications
just
so you're aware he's he's there in the
audience
um i don't know if you want to he hasn't
raised his hand or anything but
but uh my lead-off hitter on this one
okay now his hand is up here i'll
am i unmuted now you are
oh there we go i'm sorry i'm here with
tom care who um
um who's one of our lawyers um who knows
more about the
reverse auction than i do um and then
i'm likely to know more about the other
bill than he does not that he didn't
have a hand in both of them but
i'm happy to help you with anything or
talk about anything or answer anything
well we're starting with the first part
okay so i i think i i had said to your
team that on
um certainly on the um you know the
the primary piece of it is a it's just a
regular jcec
cleanup bill if you will what they do to
memorialize the decisions they made
which happens every year
making a handful of our leadership
senior leadership positions that aren't
unclassified unclassified and then
standardizing
how they're treated based on uh uh who
they are and
the directors and above have a term
governing council
sure director levels that so i think
it's fairly straightforward
and that's the amendment that you
yeah representative licorich has a
question hi uh thank you
for uh for a layman would you just give
a
i don't know two maybe three sentences
just to
um you know
lay out for me why the changes are and
what are the
key advantages just simple terms sure
um so in the state system most employees
are classified
this is this is the executive branch the
legislative branch has its own pace
schedules and the
judicial branch does its own thing too
but in the executive branch
the lion's share of employees are our um
un
are classified employees dated dating to
the implementation of the merit system
in 1940
um based on social security act
amendments um
what it what it means functionally is
that they are all hourly employees
who are placed into uh one of 35 levels
on a grid
a grid that has nine steps but has 35
labor grades the positions are evaluated
and placed on that
over the history of the state senior
positions
are called um officers
of the state um and at the time as the
treasurer and the comptroller and the
the major department heads and it became
a slightly broader group over time
are are salaried employees in an
unclassified grid
it's also a grid where most employees
are on
a labor grade they're lettered instead
of numbered
a a is the is the lowest and um
i believe that the governor and the
commissioner of health and human
services are both mm
which is the um there are higher grades
but there's almost nobody at them
except i think the medical examiner um
so but people are placed on that grid
commissioners across the the state are
all on that level assistant
commissioners and deputy commissioners
um and most directors many directors
state it's
sort of hit and miss in our department
some directors are some directors aren't
classified or unclassified think of
classified as hourly
unclassified as salaried those are the
major distinctions between the two
um many of our senior leadership
positions
are but not all of them are the
advantage is to
make a consistent group from our
from our department standpoint so every
director is not
almost every director we have some
deputy directors who are
some deputy directors who aren't this
will be all
deputy directors and then a handful of
similar positions
in terms of the level of responsibility
that they have
such that they are senior management the
additional ones are we have a position
called senior operational analyst
um that position is unclassified but we
would make clear that it would be like
all
other classified below division which is
that they serve
um pleasure of the commissioner as
opposed to for a term which means
not so much that it doesn't mean so much
that that they're that you know they
they live and die on my whim it means
that um
they don't have a term that ends where
their job ends
and they must be reappointed they just
they just have a job
um it would also be true of the internal
auditor a position that's currently
vacant
um the plant and properties
um superintendents or bureau chiefs
the people who are responsible for
positions that at one time were the
superintendent of building and grounds
um back in the day um those three major
positions these are all
positions that are at the very highest
levels of the
classified salary grid that
realistically function as if they were
salaried employees
um but don't actually function that way
because they're
they're hourly they do an hourly time
card and
and it's you have to be careful about
you know calling them after hours or
it's 4 30 we can't still be meeting um
and things like that
so they would they would become like all
other senior leadership positions
so christopher also in part one after
after we go through the just the
boilerplate stuff
to codify jason
there is a change being
placed here on the chairmanship of that
actual committee to to go from a
rotation of an annual chairmanship to
so that's um i think i can speak to that
but i'm not sure for sure that's not
it's not actually our amendment that's a
decision that
the committee itself made and think uh i
think what's happened
historically is that they've done uh
house member one year senate member one
year to alternate
and and i think what they decided maybe
representative schmidt will know more
but i think what they decided is that
operationally
um that's too much it changes too often
and so they still want to switch back
and forth between the house and senate
but want to have it switch back and
forth on the biennium
instead of on the anum as it were and i
think it's it's for simplicity's sake
and and because so many things um
so many things cross an annual line you
know you might have a meeting in
december
and then the follow-up meeting is in
january or february
um and it's a year whereas typically
um if you use the election year as the
barometer
things don't actually cross over on that
and so it's it's
i think it's it's simply operational
efficiency
um so that instead of it being
representative schmidt one year
and senator reagan the next it would be
representative of schmidt one biennium
or whoever um and senator reagan the
next
and i think it's just for operational
purposes
so as far as part one goes with this do
we have any uh
remember that i'm sure thank you mr
chair
uh good afternoon commissioner i'm
curious
you mentioned that um
with the hourly employees that
say you're in a meeting and it's going
beyond
4 30 their time to quit work
um what happens if they should stay
beyond that
well in the under the current scheme
there are
there are significant um there's a
significant body of regulation that the
federal government has under flsa
the i think that's fair labor standards
act
and um um there are a whole bunch of
rules and regulations some of them deal
with
the distinctions between exempt and
non-exempt which
um in most private businesses in most
states frankly
um tip are typically not exclusively but
typically based on salary level where
people are treated
somewhat differently you know certain
employees and and you can
understand this think about like our
grounds crew
they are early employees they're meant
to be hourly employees and and
and they're very strict rules and
regulations whereas managerial positions
are treated differently because of the
you must work a 37 and a half hour week
you must keep a time card that is
accurate for a 37 and a half hour week
if you work a 38th or 39th hour you must
be
paid an additional x
per hour for that the statutes
or i'm sorry the budget tends to not
allow for overtime there's some
positions that it does and you budget
for them
but not for that so you there are very
strict sort of
rules and regulations on on you know
what time did you get here did you hear
it here at 8 10 or at 8 12.
um did you leave at 4 30 or 4 36 if i
uh send you a text at home at night you
know i'm
obviously doing a lot of work at night
um and if i send you a text or an email
at home you should not open it until
first thing in the morning
and you know there are a lot of
employees who just don't worry about it
and do it anyway
technically you're in violation right
where
where you know they they're not meant to
come in on a saturday
because if you come in on a saturday i
have to pay you and i didn't
and i'm not budgeted for that so you
must stay home we early in my tenure
here there was an employee who was
disciplined for working too much
and um and it just it felt really weird
right
like we were giving someone a hard time
for working too much
and it was because they had no budget
for overtime
and and um and she said i don't care i'm
gonna put in for it
and her manager said i can't i i can't
let you
decide to ignore that and she said this
is ridiculous
you know i'm making 90 000 a year
whatever she made it was something like
that
and it's it's you know i'm working a
38th hour
i'm not doing 75 hours a week i'm just
working an extra half hour to
catch up on stuff it's like i'm sorry
you're not you're not a salaried
employee you're an hourly employee and
we have to treat you as such
and um and i'm not critical of that
because those those
restrictions are in place to protect
employees from abuse from supervisors
and
and um but in the most senior positions
in state government
it's uh it's it's more than reasonable
to expect people to be salaried
and the only and they expect it too
frankly they're they're
if you start from the outside you just
think it's weird um
and so um we're taking
only our most senior positions because
you know beyond that you
there are all kinds of other
considerations you would have to get